rejoints tout de suite notre envoyé
spécial dans la capitale ukrainienne
gulliver craag bonjour gilbert les
ukrainiens ont été affectés par la
guerre de plusieurs manières vous avez
parlé à une employée du magasin leroy
merlin qui a été bombardé il ya quelques
jours qu'est ce qu'elle vous a dit
oui vous savez les emplois et ukrainiens
de leroy merlin sont en rébellion
ouverte contre la maison mère après le
bombardement de l'un des leurs magasins
à kiev le 20 mars ils ont lancé une
pétition pour appeler à la maison mère
de leroy merlin de cesser ses activités
commerciales avec la russie ce que la
compagnie a refusé de faire citons
diverses argumentation pour justifier de
cela les employés craignaient n'était
pas du tout d'accord est ce qu'ils m'ont
raconté aujourd'hui j'en ai parlé à deux
d'entre eux en réalité ils ont dit
qu'ils ont été coupés de tout accès aux
réseaux sociaux de l'entreprise
interdits d'accès au magasin de leroy
merlin qui reste intacte à kiev et
ailleurs en ukraine et oui du coup ils
sont vraiment entrés en guerre ouverte
et ils veulent faire du bruit autour de
cette question je ne sais pas si elle
est emblématique de la situation
d'autres compagnies européennes qui ont
des filiales en ukraine ou non mais ils
ont plus de ce problème du rejet de
l'appel de la pétition des employés
ukrainien de leroy merlin il me
racontait que la maison mère refuse
d'aider la compagnie à payer ses dettes
envers ses clients ukrainiens qui ont
très grand nombre avaient commandé des
articles souvent des choses assez cher
des cuisines entière et c'est qu'ils
n'ont pas pu être livré pour des raisons
évidentes surtout ceux qui avaient été
commandés au magasin qui était
totalement détruite et attend qu'il
voudrait vraiment de l'aide de la de la
compagnie merde de leroy merlin en
france pourrait ce qu'est aider à
rembourser ne serait-ce que rembourser
ses clients ukrainien qui sans doute
souffre de bien d'autres manières aussi
de cette guerre et n'avait pas du tout
besoin de perdre l'argent qu'ils avaient
investie dans leur cuisine ou autres
éléments de maisons et gulliver qu'en
est il des combats à kiev et autour de
la capitale
alors depuis le centre ville de kehl
j'entends moins de bruit aujourd'hui que
je n'entendais hier soir mais on entend
un peu quand même et puis ce matin
j'avais l'intention de me rendre
meilleur qu'à une ville au sud ouest et
de kiev qui était un peu mais pas
beaucoup touché au cours de ce conflit
et un représentant du ministère de
l'intérieur on m'a dit que ce n'était
pas possible d'y aller aujourd'hui pour
des raisons de sécurité donc il faut
croire que il y à des tirs dans cette
direction là aussi globalement on a
l'impression qu'une partie des forces
russes se retire peut-être pour se
redéployer pour l'est ou peut-être pour
juste se regrouper et se déployer à
nouveau en direction de kiev pour le
moment on ne le sait pas les
renseignements britanniques redoutent
une nouvelle offensive sur la région de
kiev dans les jours qui viennent
merci gulliver craque pour toutes ces
précisions